قررت اداره الطيران الفيدرالي الامريكي
وفق رحلات جويه الى مدينه نيويورك بسبب
ضعف الرؤيه الناتجه عن حرائق الغابات اقلت
اداره الطيران ان الرحلات الجويه المتجهه
الى مطار نيويورك اما توقفت مؤقتا او
تاخرت عن موعد وصولها في مغطى دخان
الحرائق سماء نيويورك ومبنى الامم المتحده
وينضم الينا من نيويورك الصحفي طارق
الدمشقي اهلا بك السيد طارق يعني الى جانب
توقيف حركه
الطيران بشكل جزئي في مدينه نيويورك هل من
اجراءات خاصه تم اتخاذها من قبل السلطات
تحيه لك راويه نعم هناك يعني عمده مدينه
نيويورك ادم صرح اليوم ان هذه الكثافه من
الدخان الذي تتعرض لها المنطقه عموما بسبب
حرائق الغابات في كندا لم تشهد مثقلها
البلاد منذ عام 1960 يعني منذ 60 عاما هذا
التلوث دفع
العمده الى اتخاذ قرارات بمنع الانشطه
الخارجيه بشكل عام الى على كافه المارس
الموجوده في المنطقه كذلك ولايه نيوجيرسي
القريبه جدا من مدينه نيويورك المحاذيه
لها اتخذت اجراءات مماثله هناك دعوه كبيره
تحث الناس على البقاء في اماكن المغلقه في
منازلهم او في اماكن عملهم عدم الخروج عند
الا عند الضروره القصوى
التلوث وصل الى درجه جدا عاليه ولكن
يعني المرشد للنظر ان حكومه مدينه نيويورك
ابدت استعدادات ورفعت الجاهزيه في
المستشفيات لاستقبال حالات الربو الازمات
الربو وايضا
الازمات القلبيه لانهم هناك توقعات
يتوقعون ان هذه
هذا الجو المتلوث سوف يؤدي الى حالات
كبيره جدا من ازمات قلبيه وازمات ربو فهم
على اعلى استعداد الان لذلك انا الان في
الخارج جالس في سيارتي واستطيع ان انقل
لكم الصوره ان ما يحدث الان في يعني في
هذه المناطق ناطحات السحاب العاليه جدا
المعروفه في مدينه نيويورك يعني لا استطيع
ان ارى القريبه مني نتيجه هذا التلوث بسبب
الدخان الحاله تشبه نوعا ما العواصف
الرمليه التي تصيب الدول العربيه في
الخليج خصوصا مثل العجاج ولكن لا يوجد
غبار ولكنه دخان تستطيعين ان تشعري بحرقه
في العين
الجفاف في الحلق ضيق في التنفس هناك بعض
الاطباء ينصحون الناس ان ياخذوا موسع
للقصبات للتعامل مع هذه الازمه حتى وان
كانوا في الداخل
يعني حيث تتواجد انت بما انك ممم على
الطريق يعني هل هناك شلل بحركه السير بما
انه هناك نصائح من السلطات بعدم الخروج
الا في الحالات القصوى وهل تم تسجيل اي
حالات اختناق حتى الان الى جانب رفع
جهوزيات المستشفيات
لا توجد يعني تصريحات رسميه عن تسبب هذا
الامر حتى الان بحالات وفاه او اختناق
ولكن هناك الجميع يعني الجميع الاجهزه
الحكوميه الصحيه جاهزه بسبب توقعات
الخبراء ان نسبه ازمات الربو والادمات
القلبيه سوف تزداد بشكل كبير اما على
الحركه المروريه فهي نوعا ما عاديه لا
استطيع ان اقول انها غير اعتياديه الامر
الامر يعني بالنسبه لسكان نيويورك
والمناطق المحيطه بها حتى الان يعتبر يعني
مفاجاه لهم لم احد يتوقع ان تكون هذه
الغيمه الدخانيه سيئه لهذه الى هذه الدرجه
والان التصريحات الحكوميه تقول لهم ان هذا
الامر سوف يزداد قليلا او سوف يبقى على
حاله الى يوم الجمعه لذلك
يحثونهم بشده على البقاء في الاماكن
المغلقه واستخدام الجسم التكييف وايضا وضع
الكمامات
كما كان في حال ايام ايام ازمه كورونا
وحثوهم على نوع الكمامه
الخامسه والتسعين هذا الرقم
i95 انها هي افضل كمامه ممكن ان تكون
للحمايه من هذا الدخان اذا اضطررت الى
الخروج الى الخارج ولكن الدعوه العامه
البقاء داخل المنازل في التكييف وعدم فتح
النوافذ ويعني الكل ياخذ اعلى درجات
الحيطه كما تفعل الان الحكومه على عالم
مستويات انشطه المدارس تقريبا يعني
الخارجيه التغت بشكل كامل في كل المنطقه
ليست فقط في منطقه نيويورك كما ذكرت لك في
منطقه مدن ان ولايه نيوجيرسي القريبه جدا
من نيويورك هذا يعني ما استطيع ان انقله
حتى الان
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد طارق الدمشقي الصحافي
من نيويورك شكرا جزيلا
عبر الهاتف ايضا ينضم الينا من عمان كابتن
طيار مدني السيد يوسف الدعجه اهلا بك سيد
يوسف يعني موقع اي كيو ار
قال بانه مؤشر جوده الهواء في نيويورك
اليوم وصل الى 167 درجه لتحتل بذلك
المرتبه الثانيه عالميا من حيث رداءت
الهواء بعد العاصمه الهنديه نيودلهي كيف
يمكن وصف الصوره التي نشاهدها مباشره من
مدينه نيويورك
صحيح الوضع سيء جدا في مدينه نيويورك او
في ولايه نيويورك نيوجيرسي من الحرائق
التي ذكرتموها وهي لم تحدث منذ 1960 الجو
وصل لدرجه من درجه انعدام الرؤيه خصوصا من
الحالات الطائرات الى درجه لربما يصعب ان
يكون هنالك هبوط واقلاع في المطارات
المتواجد في هذه الحرائق لان هذه الحرائق
وهذا الاشيز اللي هو الرماد من الحرائق لا
يرتفع الى طبقات الجو العليا ولا تؤثر على
الطائرات من الناحيه التقنيه ولكن سوف
تؤثر على الطائرات في حاله الاقلاع
والهبوط ولكن الطائرات الحديثه مجهزه
باجهزه بحيث يستطيع ان تهبط في حاله اذا
كانت حتى مدى الرؤيه صفر يعني لا يكون
هناك رؤيه وهذه بحاجه الى طيارين مهره
ومتدربين والطائره يجب ان تكون مجهزه لهذا
الطيران المدني الامريكي اعلن عن توقف
جزئي لحركه الطيران بالنيويورك هل يمكن
بما انه تتحدث عن ان هل يمكن ان يستمر
اكثر اما من ناحيه الركاب داخل الطائره
خصوصا تبع الطائره سوف يقوم بشفط هذه
الغبار وادخالها الى المكيفات الداخليه
والى اجهزه الطائره الداخليه وهذا يتطلب
نوع من الصيانه والتنظيف والقوست العالي
على شركات الطائرات ولربما يعرض الحاله
الجسديه والحاله النفسيه الركاب داخل
الطائر عندما يستنشقون ثاني اكسيد الكربون
من من هذه الغبار والاشز المتناثره في
الجو يؤثر عليهم صحيا ولربما قاموا بدعوات
قضائيه الى هذه على الشركات ولكن يفضل في
هذه الحالات بالذات اللا يقترب التيار من
المنطقه التي يوجد فيها هذه الغبار لانها
تؤثر على اجهزه الطائره تؤثر على تبع
الطائره تؤثر على صحه الطيارين
والمسافرين لانهم سوف يقومون باستنشاق
ثاني اكسيد الكربون ولربما دخل بعضهم في
حاله غيبوبه وهذا امر صعب جدا
وبراي انه سوف يقوم باغلاق المجال الجوي
تحت عشره الاف قدم في مدينه نيويورك او
المدينه او المناطق المحيطه في هذه
الحرائق ونرجو السلام للجميع باذن الله
سيد يوسف يعني درجه يعني فرض هذا القرار
تتحدث عن كيلومترات معينه يعني كيف تختلف
الطبقات الجو كما
هي مكيفه او موجوده
ثقيل جدا لا يرتفع الى اكثر من عشره الاف
قدم لربما بالكثير فطبقات الجو العليا او
اللي هي المجال الجوي لن يغلق ولكن الهبوط
والاقلاع هو من سوف يتاثر لان الانشز وهي
من الحرائق وهي الرماد خلينا نحكي من
الحراك والاشجار تكون ثقيله وهذه تهبط الى
مستويات المستويات
الواطيه في في الغلاف الجوي الدنيا نعم
خلال الهبوط والاقناع هنا تكمن الخطوره
ويجب على شركات الطيران او الطيار بالذات
هو صاحب المسؤوليه ان يقوم باختيار مطار
بديل غير مطارات التي تكون في محيط
السيد يوسف تنصح في هكذا حالات الطيارين
باختيار مدينه اخرى ربما او مطار اخر
لضمان الهبوط الامن نصائح دعنا نذكر
بنصائح سيد يوسف من جديد يعني في حال
امتدت هذه او حصلت باماكن اخرى
طبعا يا سيدتي ويوجد بروسيس وتعليمات في
الطيار يعلمها في حاله وجود اللي هو كانك
عاشز اللي هو الحرائق من الاشجار او
الحرائق الارضيه او لربما البراكين هنالك
تعليمات وواضحه عدم الدخول الى هذه
المناطق ويجب الابتعاد عنها حتى لا تؤثر
على اجهزه الطائره لان في اجهزه الطائره
هي دقيقه وحساسه وغاليه جدا يعني بعض
الكمبيوتر يكلف 3 مليون 4 مليون واذا دخلت
علي هذه الغبار تعطله وتعطل الطائره
ولربما عطلت اجهزه الطائره وتوجيه الطائره
لربما انها عرضت السلام الجويه للطائره
وعرضت الركاب للخطوره فانا انصح وربما هذه
تعليمات
الفتره الذي سوف يقوم باصدار بوليتن
للطيارين والمطارات باغلاقها او الاتجاه
الى مطار بديل بعيد جدا عن هذه الحاله
الجويه او الحاله الحرائق الحاصله ليان
الان في الشرقيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولربما لا ننسب لن تكون فقط
نيويورك سوف تكون نيويورك
عنه يعني قد تتاثر مدن اخرى كمدينه
نيويورك نعم
هذه الولايات اللي هي على السواحل الشرقيه
الامريكيه الممتده الى
الشمال الشرقي من كندا شرقي من ريال
سوف تتاثر هذه المنطقه كلها من لانه
الرياح غربيه وسوف تقوم بدفع هذه الغبار
الى الجنوب الشرقي ناحيه السواحل الشرقيه
الامريكيه وخصوصا مدينه نيويورك
سوف تتاثر سوف تتاثر تاثرا كاملا ولربما
سوف تتعطل السياحه لا ننسى على شلالات
نياجرا في بافلو الشم وهي على الحدود
الكنديه وهي مشتركه سوف تتعطل السياحه ميه
في الميه وسوف يكون بحاجه الى ايام كثيره
حتى يقوموا باصلاح او تنظيف ما خلطته هذه
الحرائق بعد الانتهاء هذه الحرائق بكم يوم
او اسبوع يمكن ان تعود الرؤيه واضحه ويمكن
للطياره ان تطير بامان دون الاضرار
بالمحركات او حتى بالركاب من خلال الهواء
الذي يتنشقونه
كما ذكرت سابقا الحرائق
والاشز والمتناثر من هذه الحرائق يهبط الى
طبقات الجو
السفلى ثم يهبط الى الارض
خلال سويعات ربما او ايام ولكن لنتذكر
شيئا ان بعد كل حرائق سوف تكون هنالك
امطار رعديه سبحان الله
وتنظف المجال الجوي المجال الج لن يكون
عليه اي خطوره بعد انتهاء الحرائق لربما ب
24 ساعه على 48 ساعه المجال الجوي في
طبقات الجو
السفلى اللي تحت 10,000 قدم لن سوف تتاثر
اما طبقات الجو العليا لن تصل هذه
الاشيز او الى هذه الطبقات ربما تحتاج الى
ايام وفي بعض المناطق المطارات يقوم
بتنظيفها يعني بجوز خلال ساعات لانها لن
تكون بهذاك التاثير التي تتراكم كما هي
الفولكانيك اللي هي البراكين البراكين
بحاجه الى ايام وربما اسابيع حتى تنظيف
المناطق حول المطار لانها مواد من
البتروليه التي تلتصق وتلصق في اجهزه
الطائره وهي اقل العراق اقل اقل خطوره من
الفلكانيك حياك الله يا شيخ
اذا الكابتن الطيار المدني يوسف الدعجه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات